Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je me suis réveillé ce matin
avec une petite musique dans la tête.
Ça vous arrive peut-être à vous aussi,
ces petites musiques
qui reviennent régulièrement.
C’est étonnant, ces musiques entêtantes
qui nous envahissent.
Pour beaucoup d’entre nous,
certaines chansons, certaines musiques
constituent des marqueurs très, très forts
de notre identité
et de notre autobiographie.
Je vais vous raconter
un fait divers tout à fait étonnant.
Le 7 août 2008, le Daily Telegraph publie
un article, en fait, qui n’est pas unique,
mais qui est assez extraordinaire.
À Londres, Sam Carter,
boulanger à la retraite,
fait un infarctus et tombe dans le coma.
Les médecins estimaient qu’il avait
des chances de survie d’environ 30 %.
Sa femme est présente.
Les médecins lui disent : « Vous savez,
pour que la chambre
ne soit pas silencieuse,
ça serait bien de laisser
la radio allumée,
au cas où. »
Au bout de trois jours,
Sam se réveille
en entendant la fameuse chanson
des Rolling Stones « Satisfaction ».
C’était le premier disque
qu’il avait acheté, en 1965.
Quand il s’est réveillé, il a déclaré :
« Quand j’ai entendu cette musique,
je me suis rappelé ma jeunesse.
Je me suis rappelé ma vitalité
à cette époque.
J’ai pensé : ‘Ah oui, la vie,
elle vaut le coup d’être vécue.’
Et ça m’a donné
envie de continuer de vivre. »
Ce type d’exemple
tout à fait extraordinaire
de réveil de coma
à l’écoute d’une musique,
on en a régulièrement de publié
dans nos médias et nos journaux.
Et ça montre quoi ?
Ça montre effectivement que la musique
est une madeleine puissante pour aller
chercher des souvenirs personnels
et faire émerger des souvenirs
parfois même enfouis.
Les relations entre mémoire et musique,
c’est ce que j’étudie
depuis un peu plus de vingt ans
dans mon unité de recherche
qui s’intéresse à la mémoire humaine
et à ses troubles.
Je suis chercheur en psychologie,
plus spécifiquement en neuropsychologie.
et donc l’objectif de mes recherches
est de mieux diagnostiquer
et de mieux prendre en charge
des patients qui ont
des maladies du cerveau.
Et là, la musique se révèle
extrêmement précieuse
pour, d’une part, mieux comprendre
comment la mémoire
fonctionne dans notre cerveau ;
d’autre part,
pour savoir comment la musique
pourrait modifier notre cerveau,
Et, aussi, comment la musique
pourrait soigner, guérir notre cerveau.
Par exemple, nous avons montré
en neuro-imagerie cérébrale
que la mémoire de la musique active
des régions du cerveau très, très larges
par rapport, en fin de compte,
à la mémoire du langage.
La mémoire du langage utilise
un réseau très spécialisé.
C’est une fonction extrêmement
pointue, sur-apprise,
Alors que la musique, la mémoire musicale,
va envahir notre cerveau
de manière beaucoup plus large,
beaucoup plus diffuse,
Et ça, c’est déjà un avantage.
Quand il y a une maladie du cerveau,
en fin de compte, la musique,
la mémoire musicale
est beaucoup plus résistante
à ces maladies.
Par ailleurs, nous avons montré
chez les musiciens,
en regardant,
comparant le cerveau des musiciens,
des gens qui avaient fait au moins
15, 20 ans d’études de musique -
Dans ce cerveau des musiciens,
par rapport à des non-musiciens,
il y a des modifications
liées à leur pratique
et notamment des modifications dans
les régions du cerveau liées à la mémoire,
que l’on appelle les hippocampes.
Plus ils pratiquent de la musique,
de leur instrument,
plus on va trouver
une densité de neurones,
une augmentation de l’épaisseur
corticale dans ces régions.
Le cerveau change
par la pratique de la musique.
Enfin, au niveau des patients Alzheimer,
on remarque que ces patients,
malgré la maladie qui avance,
conservent une mémoire de la musique
très, très, très, en fin de compte,
préservée, très présente.
Vous avez sans doute vu cette vidéo
qui a fait le buzz
de cette ancienne ballerine atteinte d’une
maladie d’Alzheimer à un stade avancé
à qui on fait écouter
« Le lac des cygnes ».
Et là, d’un seul coup, elle s’éveille
et elle retrouve la chorégraphie
du « Lac des cygnes »,
qu’elle a dansée durant sa jeunesse.
Plus étonnant encore, avec la musique,
nous avons pu démontrer
que ces patients Alzheimer,
très amnésiques,
pouvaient encore apprendre de nouvelles
chansons qu’ils ne connaissaient pas
et apprendre de nouveaux airs,
alors même qu’ils ne se souviennent pas
d’avoir appris quelque chose de nouveau.
Leur cerveau retient la musique alors même
que leur cerveau est très amnésique.
On pensait que c’était impossible,
mais la musique nous a permis de démontrer
que leur mémoire, en fin de compte,
n’est pas complètement abolie
et que grâce à la musique,
on peut arriver à la stimuler.
Alors, qu’est-ce que tout ça
nous permet de dire ?
Que la musique et la mémoire musicale,
elles fonctionnent beaucoup,
évidemment, avec les émotions,
et on peut penser que la fonction
principale de la musique,
c’est de produire des émotions.
C’est une idée tout à fait familière
de penser que la musique est là
pour nous produire des émotions -
c’est tout à fait le cas,
la plupart du temps -
et que c’est assez universel,
que l’on va trouver effectivement ce
caractère universel des émotions musicales
dans toutes les sociétés humaines.
Mais il y a un premier constat à faire :
on n’aime pas tous les mêmes musiques.
On n’aime pas tous les mêmes musiques,
on vient parfois de cultures différentes,
et on peut se demander comment il pourrait
y avoir quelque chose d’universel
derrière ces goûts musicaux et ces
styles culturels extrêmement divers.
Regardons
les résultats des expériences
de neurosciences cognitives
de ces dernières années.
Dans un contexte de laboratoire,
si on fait écouter des musiques
à des participants
et qu’on leur demande de dire
si les musiques sont joyeuses ou tristes,
on voit que leurs réponses
sont très homogènes
malgré leurs différences culturelles,
malgré leurs différences
de sensibilité à la musique.
On va faire cette petite expérience.
Vous allez voir qu’en définitive,
on peut être tout à fait
majoritairement d’accord
sur le sens à donner
à une émotion musicale.
Je vais vous faire écouter
des petits extraits de musique,
que, je pense,
vous ne connaissez pas vraiment.
Ils viennent de musiques de film.
Pour chacun,
vous allez associer cette musique
à une de ces trois émotions :
joie, tristesse ou peur.
Voici le premier extrait.
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
Si ça vous a donné la patate,
je suis un peu surpris.
Deuxième extrait.
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
Si vous avez choisi la joie,
je vous demanderais de venir
après le TEDx pour me consulter.
(Rires)
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
Si vous avez peur avec cette musique,
c’est peut-être que vous avez eu
un mauvais souvenir avec des clowns.
Bon.
Vous voyez que globalement,
on est tous assez d’accord
sur l’émotion à choisir, à catégoriser.
Ça ne veut pas forcément dire
que vous avez pris du plaisir
ou vous avez été en synchronicité
avec ces différentes émotions.
On va y revenir.
L’exercice que vous venez de faire,
c’est ce qu’a proposé Thomas Fritz
à une peuplade africaine
qu’on appelle les Mafas,
qui sont des bergers
d’Afrique équatoriale.
Il y a une dizaine d’années, il a pu
rencontrer ces Mafas, vivre avec eux.
Ces bergers sont vraiment isolés.
C’est très difficile de trouver
des peuplades très isolées dans le monde.
Les Mafas n’ont pas l’électricité.
Et vraiment, ils ne sont pas du tout
exposés à de la musique occidentale.
Quand Thomas Fritz
leur a proposé d’écouter
des musiques équivalentes,
très, très occidentales dans leur style,
ces bergers Mafas ont réussi à associer
la bonne émotion, au-delà du hasard,
de joie, de tristesse ou de peur,
en pointant les expressions faciales
sur les visages qu’ils voyaient
en écoutant la musique.
Ce qui est intéressant
dans cette expérience,
c’est que c’est la joie qui est
la mieux catégorisée par les Mafas.
Pourquoi ?
Chez les Mafas, quand on fait
de la musique - parce qu’ils en font,
ils ont des pratiques instrumentales -
quand ils font de la musique,
c’est dans les moments
joyeux de la vie sociale.
Les Mafas ont eu un peu plus de difficulté
à catégoriser les musiques tristes.
Parce que pour un Mafa, ça n’a pas
beaucoup de sens la musique triste.
Parce que la musique, on ne la fait pas
dans les moments tristes de la vie.
Donc, par cet exemple,
on voit bien
qu’on ne peut pas complètement
s’extraire du contexte culturel
dans lequel la musique se vit,
est vécue et se ressent.
Est-ce qu’il y a, malgré tout,
quelque chose d’universel
dans la perception
des émotions de la musique ?
Quand nous percevons de la musique,
que nous prenons plaisir
à l’écoute de la musique,
nous allons faire travailler, activer
ce fameux circuit de la récompense.
Dans le temps, on appelait
ce circuit « le circuit du plaisir ».
« Circuit de la récompense »,
c’est le terme qu’on utilise aujourd’hui.
Quand on prend du plaisir
à l’écoute de la musique,
on active ce circuit,
qui est un circuit très complexe.
Mais en fait, ce circuit, il n’est pas
spécifique aux plaisirs de la musique,
puisqu’il s’active aussi
pour le plaisir culinaire,
pour le plaisir lié au gain d’argent -
lorsqu’on gagne à des jeux -
et aussi pour le plaisir sexuel.
Donc, d’une certaine manière,
il n’y aurait pas
un plaisir spécifique à la musique,
un circuit pour le plaisir
spécifique à la musique,
mais malgré tout, on peut penser
que le plaisir musical s’appuie
sur des réseaux cérébraux
qui sont très utiles pour la survie
et l’adaptation de l’espèce.
Donc, du coup, le traitement des émotions
et le plaisir musical, il est universel ?
Oui, mais ce n’est peut-être
pas si simple.
On peut voir des patients qui,
à la suite de lésions cérébrales,
vont avoir ce qu’on appelle
« une anhédonie musicale ».
L’anhédonie musicale, c’est quoi ?
C’est que,
quand ils écoutent de la musique,
ils n’éprouvent pas de plaisir.
Ils l'entendent bien, mais bon,
ça ne leur fait rien.
On peut comprendre
qu’on puisse avoir une anhédonie
à la suite d’une maladie du cerveau,
par la déconnexion entre les circuits de
la perception et les circuits du plaisir.
Mais cette anhédonie musicale,
elle existe aussi chez des personnes
qui n’ont aucune maladie neurologique.
C’est ce qui a été découvert par
l’équipe de Robert Zatorre à Montréal.
En faisant ces tâches de catégorisation
musicale que vous venez de faire,
ils se sont aperçus
qu’il y avait des sujets
quand on enregistrait
l’accélération cardiaque,
la ventilation, la sudation,
ils étaient capables de catégoriser
parfaitement les mélodies,
mais, en définitive, n’avaient
aucune réaction émotionnelle.
Alors qu’il y avait des personnes qui,
en entendant des musiques joyeuses,
avaient cette accélération
cardiaque attendue.
Donc, dans la population générale,
il y a des personnes qui n’ont pas
de maladie neurologique,
qui sont tout à fait normales,
mais qui ressentent peu de plaisir
à l’écoute de la musique.
On pourrait dire qu’ils ont une sorte
anhédonie musicale non pathologique.
Mais alors, ces personnes n’éprouvent
jamais de plaisir à quoi que ce soit ?
Et c’est là que
l’équipe de Robert Zatorre,
en faisant passer ces personnes
dans un scanner,
en leur proposant notamment
des tâches de gain d’argent,
s’aperçoit qu’en fait leur circuit
du plaisir, il fonctionne bien.
Mais, si ça fonctionne bien
pour le gain d’argent,
ça ne fonctionne pas, effectivement,
pour la musique
qui n’a pas été investie par eux.
En fait, on peut comprendre
que ces personnes,
elles sont capables
de catégoriser les musiques,
comprennent intellectuellement
ce qu’est une musique joyeuse ou triste,
mais n’en n’éprouvent pas d’émotion,
ne se synchronisent pas
d’un point de vue émotionnel.
On peut faire un parallèle
avec ce qui se passe
chez certains enfants autistes qui sont
capables parfaitement d’apprendre
que quelqu’un est joyeux
ou que quelqu’un est triste
par l’orientation des traits faciaux -
quelqu’un de joyeux, quelqu’un de triste -
mais n’éprouvent jamais
d’empathie émotionnelle.
Alors, justement, on va parler
d’empathie émotionnelle
liée à la pratique de la musique.
On sait chez les enfants
que la pratique de la musique
va leur permettre
de développer
un certain nombre de capacités
intéressantes par rapport
à leurs apprentissages scolaires :
augmentation des capacités
de mémoire immédiate,
augmentation des capacités d'attention,
de concentration, etc.
Mais il y a des bénéfices aussi
extrêmement intéressants
quand on pratique la musique
ensemble, à plusieurs.
Ces bénéfices sont le fait qu’il faut
faire attention à ce que ressent l’autre,
attention à l’état mental de l’autre,
attention effectivement au fait
qu’il soit bien synchronisé avec nous.
Donc, faire de la musique ensemble,
chez les enfants,
augmente, développe
leurs capacités d’empathie.
Et ça a été étudié assez récemment,
d’un point de vue scientifique,
avec des enfants autistes.
56 enfants répartis en deux groupes -
un groupe avec intervention musicale,
un groupe sans intervention musicale -
qui ont été suivis.
Le groupe avec intervention musicale,
va augmenter ses performances
dans des tâches de communication sociale.
Et ça, ça avait déjà démontré
l’influence de la musique
sur l’augmentation des capacités
de communication sociale
chez ces enfants.
Mais ce qu’il y a en plus dans ce travail,
c’est qu’ils ont aussi montré
que la connectivité cérébrale des enfants
qui avaient eu une intervention musicale
était modifiée
et que leur cerveau se rapprochait,
en termes de configuration,
de celui des enfants normo-typiques.
Alors, la musique, elle est universelle ?
Oui, vous voyez que ce n’est
pas tout noir ou tout blanc.
Oui, la musique s’appuie sur
des compétences relativement innées,
mais si elles ne sont pas développées
durant l’enfance,
si elles ne sont pas renforcées
par des expériences
qui nous permettent de renforcer
notre plaisir, d’éduquer notre plaisir,
en définitive, on peut tout à fait
ne pas investir la musique
comme étant un domaine
qui nous apporte une satisfaction.
Et peut-être qu’on va investir
d’autres domaines comme le sport,
les jeux, la lecture.
Apprendre le plaisir,
oui, c’est une réalité,
c’est-à-dire que le plaisir,
c’est quelque chose d’inné,
mais ça s’éduque.
Ça s’éduque, et de ce fait -
Bien sûr que la musique produit
des effets intéressants
pour les enfants qui les réalisent,
pour leur scolarité.
Ça, c’est intéressant, mais en plus,
ça va leur permettre aussi de développer
leurs sentiments d’empathie
et leur capacité à vivre ensemble.
Et là, on peut se dire que
c’est un peu dommage quand même
que l’éducation artistique, et notamment
l’éducation musicale, en France,
ne soit considérée que
comme la cerise sur le gâteau
et ne soit pas le gâteau - en tout cas
une partie plus importante de ce gâteau.
Pourquoi la musique s’est-elle conservée
dans toutes les sociétés humaines ?
Est-ce que c’est par besoin effectivement
de satisfaction émotionnelle ?
Il y a un paradoxe sur le plaisir musical,
parce qu’on va trouver deux types
de comportements a priori opposés.
On va écouter de la musique
pour avoir un plaisir personnel,
solitaire.
Et puis aussi, on a le plaisir
d’être ensemble par la musique.
Écouter de la musique ensemble,
danser ensemble,
c’est vraiment une expérience
de synchronisation sociale.
Nos corps à l’unisson, nos cœurs
à l’unisson, nos cerveaux à l’unisson,
les travaux de neuro-imagerie cérébrale
montrent que c’est vrai :
nos cerveaux se synchronisent
dans leur activité.
Alors, du coup, la musique,
c’est un antidépresseur culturel.
Pourquoi pas la prescrire ?
Je pense qu’il est temps
de prescrire la musique,
car c’est un antidépresseur culturel,
mais sans effets secondaires.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)